[Applause]
by the way um have you looked up your
uber rating
i just did and i'm a little upset uh
because i'm i think i'm very nice to my
uber drivers
beyond nice at one point i even offered
to drive yeah i'm like
the best i'm the best person you want i
don't want music i don't want anything i
don't complain i don't do anything
i got a 4.88
i i rate them five stars no matter what
every time what am i going to do i'm
going to ruin somebody's life or drive
me in a car and go yeah five i don't
care five minutes i don't know if i'll
ever see you again well five five five i
don't know i don't wanna give rate
people everyone start rating people this
is gonna be a disaster of a society
where it's like hi i'm a 3.5 yeah i
figured i figured it turns out you have
a higher rating than i do ah this is
unbelievable but we've been in ubers
together many times and we will be in
many more you know i heard i did some
interview about you recently and they
actually yeah and they asked me uh
they said what's it like meeting drew
barrymore for the first time do you
remember the first time is is she iconic
you know and i said yeah she is i go
it's like meeting the statue of liberty
and then after a hundred dance parties
later you she's still the statue of
liberty but you just kind of hung out
with her and you got to know who the
statue of liberty is you're the one and
only you're drew barrymore you're iconic
it's like the statue of liberty but yeah
it's something like that like you're
like if i meet you you should be like
people freak out when they meet you i've
been with you and people meet you so the
uber drivers might freak out and be like
how could i give more than five stars
one star i don't know what they do look
at this
yes that's what i'll tell you this is
this is telling me
this is how everyone sees you
[Music]
you